[Music]
in a risky advertising news are not the
tapes of helping again submitted by get
your real ID oh we got to get long for
2020 or some [ __ ] we have to get a new
ID I do if you travel domestic oh you
need a passport says m1 on it hood but
it also says federal federal money
really yeah yeah what if you have your
password are you still good you're good
now you just have to travel with your
possible
what's domestically yeah it's in 2020
that's when that law okay cool that's
right gotta get you a real ID deal or
receive backlash for advertising for an
advertising campaign starring Johnny
Depp wow this is slosh yeah because he's
not a beautiful man anymore would be
beautiful Steve I don't disagree I'm he
looks like the melted version of him his
hot self oh that is so perfect he looked
like he'd been through some stuff yeah
it's like the wacom you was abusing him
though yeah his wife yes Mike turns out
his wife was abusing him November her
day with what hot wax so he looks like a
melted hot wax museum Johnny Depp
there's the hot wax him looks better
oh for sure yeah for sure Madame
Tussauds def is a hundred times better
than him bro have you ever walked
through there it's pretty good job all
around the corner and it feels like
those are roomful of people but they're
not people you like I guarantee I was in
London in that my kids were freaking out
like oh this is cool I was like let's
get out of here man yeah this is real
you feel him up I try to feel them ah
alright I felt them off alright
the Dior ad that we are talking about is
it molesting if I'm sticking my dick
inside of wax nope oh [ __ ] waxed people
don't have right you can say not yes I
mean it's a piece of art you're here you
go
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
beautiful shot I want to go to a powwow
okay I don't I just think it's a
dope-ass commercial maybe I don't
understand I was aware of the cabbage or
something in front to translate to butt
in Bulgarian and means sausage and I saw
him roasting the sausage in the campfire
true history behind this that's [ __ ]
hilarious
is Dior's established salvage line which
dates back to 1966 and the name has been
said to been inspired by Christian
Dior's friend named Percy Savage who
when he would go to doors home to
brainstorm name ideas he was introduced
by the butler as miss Madea Sauvage so
then that's how they came out with it
that okay it's a great story is this a
[ __ ] shitty coincidence like that cuz
I've know some boss has been around for
a minute this is the first time they
marketed it like this no plus everyone
says Savage now I was like your [ __ ]
this guy's a [ __ ] Savage dude so that
was a big mistake
native-american connotation it's just by
your savage that's all races racial slur
for Native America it is savages their
scalping people Disney uses it yeah
savages there's a [ __ ] song really
the white people were the savages John
John Smith yeah things are just savage
period agency got pissed yes
yeah haven't seen Pocahontas in a while
but yes I mean that is so it's amazing
so why are people pissed again okay
because of the fact that they're using
the word that is with Native American
you know what it's like I'm gonna do it
I didn't ask job question because he's
the historian okay in the French and
Indian War what they Allies yes of
course so if you're using the French
version of savage it's like saying homie
but they did call them savages they call
them savages
it's a French company with Indian art
work his stories accurate or not if
listen Sauvage it's translated to wild
or untamed same as savage right so the
fact that just like what kept something
I like being savage it's used as like a
flirt towards Native Americans yeah it's
our history okay dr tried to do their
best in their own way because they did
hire a Native American consulting agency
or to help with this
oh and nobody called that and they just
wanted to get people obviously don't
even leave the Native Americans are
pissed this Paul the other Pino it is no
no it is oh oh they're pissed even
people that were involved with this
advert advertisement here are we are
they
consorted we know know the actress that
was in no it was for Sivaji new and she
actually posted on instagram this really
really long thing about her explaining
pretty much how Native Americans there
they don't have many roles to select in
like in the film industry I know she did
they can play an Indian that's exactly
the only option they hired and so she
said like in order for her
okay painter maybe she said that no
matter what they were gonna but they
were gonna make this ad with or without
her so she decided to take on the job
and donate the money that she got all
that's tight but [ __ ] yes - she got the
job but she's complaining about it but
she is gonna donate the money - she's
given the Indians dirty money it's dirty
money she said that you know like she's
trying to get - she's trying to get her
career to a place where she can wait she
can be in a position to really oppose
this but as of right now she just kind
of has to climb the ladder play the game
yeah I don't blame her to play the game
- because there's a lot of wet bucket
that's like just putting an accent on
something like that new fragrance from
Dior and again just how much the black
people's Blaine dies
not what the harm that means what would
you wouldn't you want to take it up and
smile and just smell what that smells
like
I would not want what Pacquiao's like
talking about motion oh all the
blackboard
yeah the coconut though as a collage oh
you're gonna do just change the v2s on
all the bottles no because it's saw Bosh
but if you change it to so size then
it's about leaners now sausage and then
it should that should change it to a
meteor smell to commercial I want to be
in cheese nips G wide because I'm in uh
what is that one that's a derogatory
term for Japanese I didn't know white
person Steve there's no cleaning as we
call them zipper heads and I like that
one that's that's after us that's that's
after okay Vietnamese and Koreans he's
like in granters and your [ __ ] zipper
head think he just makes those movies so
he can say that what's the story I know
I just want to say that I have a lot of
lines either
so he's like yeah I just didn't I'm
gonna call you zipper head but that's
the whole gran torino thing yeah just
like yeah next one he's gonna come out
with a cartel movie and another one is
gonna do a timepiece about slavery and
like yeah like you see say every single
word
Oh cartel movie he did see the cartel on
me well that damn you'll write so
calling people speaks and stuff although
I don't know anything you would like you
I bet you he did all that you know and
context to all right so anyway so side
note here Johnny depth claims that he
has Native American ancestry and he says
I he claims to have either a Cherokee or
Creek nobody cares because you look
white and so in the long range er yeah
he played that character he was like an
honorary member of some Native American
group but he refuses to verify his
ancestry so people are like take the
23andme full yeah they're just like what
the 23 me doesn't show that we know that
for a fact
it is a show native now because Native
American you have to be part of their
tribe that's not even a genetic test per
se it's that you're part of their tribe
so yeah it's like a more like a written
history yeah yeah like they have to
chase your dad and your grandfather like
back to to the tribe oh it's not about
your genetic code or whatever the [ __ ]
that that's all that's all misnomer I
see so there's people that have Native
American ancestry but they're not
considered Native American because
they're not they don't belong to a tribe
that's the whole thing is you've got to
belong to the tribe
belong to a tribe a tribe sounds so cool
try take it from me yeah but we're not
wearing feathers and like we don't have
a theme you know like the cultures just
we're wearing regular clothes but take
it with a grain of salt because I used
to fast-forward to the Indian parts of
the Peter Pan movie because I didn't
like them that much how they were boring
parts of the movie with the whole peace
pipe scene I was like this is so slow
and I would try to get back to the
fighting stuff our people mad at D or
more or Johnny Depp more or like Johnny
Depp is just like the Native American
actress right where she he's just part
of the project he's not the creator of
get mad at the actor that was before
that commercial I saw was the girl that
I've seen once of Oz before
yeah and I don't think people were ever
really mad about it but I'll be happy
Native American imagery exactly maybe
ever tied it to Native America well how
dope was that dancing though everything
they just [ __ ] that up with the name
it not secular that lasts everything was
good until that last second that came oh
I look like you're black Cologne imagine
it was like all of these like black guys
in the hood it's cool and everything is
like barbershop
should I be yeah
yeah we could have just win with black
yeah yeah Negro Negro means black and
Spanish right let's do your 1/8 his
kicking is I want to read a quote from
the actress okay on her like Instagram
thing so she said I do believe do your
although a misguided had every intention
of showing indigenous culture in a
beautiful light while giving some jobs
to some Indians in the process one of
the native advisers for the ad who I had
a lot of great conversations with put
his heart into this job and I admire him
for the efforts he made to try and
maintain cultural integrity I want to
acknowledge his efforts and can cooz
who's the the dancer work because
sometimes our hard work can get lost
first in the message and then in the
media storm I do think that I don't know
if this is the case with you or I think
sometimes companies have good intentions
with their tote they're so automated
they'd doesn't really matter what your
intention were you just look so dumb and
like off basis possible Iguchi and then
the other one too if that was cool water
it'd be fine you mean like yeah hmm
there's a lot of names you could have
gone away got away with it and sold that
same commercial yeah but honestly I
think at this point they're just really
trying to they know the culture yeah
doing this for free publicity you really
want free publicity and they're really
trying to start some [ __ ] up and it's
working because they even know like if
they're a French company and they don't
know the history with Native Americans
and like the colonialism had Native
American yeah maybe just for art
direction maybe just for a visual a stab
wound but they don't know the historical
step I think that their advisors are
pretty lazy this guy's mean
[Music]